on July 14 2015 after nearly a decade
since launching the space probe New
Horizons finally passed by Pluto
thrilling scientists and dreamers alike
New Horizons instruments are mapping and
measuring the dwarf planet 3 billion
miles away from Earth New Horizons has
already begun the slow process of
sending back the clearest images of
Pluto we've ever seen the little probe
is also imaging Pluto's moons including
Karen New Horizons will shoot the hazard
strewn gap around Pluto and Charon its
eyes probing the system if all goes
according to plan around four-thirty
p.m. eastern time the pro-bowl turned
toward Earth and start sending that data
home then we'll finally know for sure
that New Horizons has made it through
its most dangerous moment it will take a
year and a half to download the rest of
the information which should illuminate
the last of our solar system's mysteries
including one unknown body even further
out in the Kuiper belt maybe that icy
Rock will someday be as beloved as our
dear Pluto but don't bet on it